eurent fouillé dans le massif alpin déjà
plus de quarante activistes tués depuis
la mi juillet mise en orbite sans
problème pour les deux cosmonautes
russes se charger du dépannage de la
station mir
dans ce journal nous reviendrons
également sur une nouvelle découverte
dans le traitement de la maladie de
parkinson
la nouvelle fraude à la carte bancaire
et non viendront bien sûr sur la
victoire au 400 m haies de stéphane
diagana hier soir stéphane diagana
premier rapt est sensé et champion du
monde il ya quelques minutes à athlone
l'américain michael johnson a conservé
son titre mondial sur 400 m
voilà monsieur bonsoir cinq personnes
dont deux gendarmes ont été tués et deux
autres blessés dans une fusillade en fin
d'après midi près de châteaubourg en
ille et vilaine près de rennes
selon les premiers témoignages ces deux
gendarmes intervenaient sur un différend
familial je vous propose d'entendre
maintenant un premier témoignage que
nous venons de recevoir celui d'agent
sein du peloton de gendarmerie de rennes
il ya eu un différend familial les
gendarmes ont été appelés se sont rendus
immédiatement sur les lieux et il
semblerait que à peine arrivés sur les
lieux ils étaient pris à partie par une
personne et qui leur a tiré dessus
malheureusement il a touché mortellement
touché les deux hommes seront donc ça
c'est de ces deux éléments sûrs quant au
reste pour l'instant nous savons que les
push de l'auteur qui aurait tué son
également décédé et qu'il y aurait une
autre personne décédée
l'auteur lui on ne sait toujours pas
s'il est mort ou pas mort dans l'état
actuel de l'enquêté cinq pour moi qui
suis au bureau il y aurait deux autres
deux autres personnes blessées et je ne
sais pas qui pour les chats je veux pas
dire davantage
malheureusement un boeing 747 de la
korean airlines avec 300 trente et une
personnes à bord s'est abîmé sur cette
l'île de guam dans le pacifique
il y à quelques minutes donc trois cent
trente et une personnes à bord et selon
des premiers témoignages il y aurait eu
une trentaine de survivants été
meurtrier dans le massif alpin avec
aujourd'hui un nouveau drame sur le
versant italien des dolomites où au
moins huit alpinistes ont trouvé la mort
depuis la mi juillet
les accidents dans le massif alpin ont
déjà fait plus de quarante victimes
syrie kurt et en une journée huit morts
et peut-être plus une personne est
encore portée disparue près de bolzano
dans le massif italien des dolomites
c'est d'abord une cordée de quatre
alpinistes qui a dévissé
les secours avaient été alertés par un
guide et s'accorder située dans la même
paroisse
mais peu de temps après ces trois
personnes chutait aussi de plusieurs
dizaines de mètres
aucune n'a survécu ce week end a été
particulièrement meurtrier dans les
alpes françaises suisses et
autrichiennes aussi en tout douze morts
pour ces trois derniers jours et ce
malgré une météo clémente
le bilan depuis le début de la saison
dépasse les 40 morts on le vérifie donc
dramatiquement cette année la montagne
et parfois traîtresse pour les amateurs
mal aguerrie elle malgré tout malgré les
risques de nombreux passionnés
continuent cependant à escalader les
cimes
reportage à chamonix didier guyot flip
avec le mont blanc chaque jour par
centaines les alpinistes tentent
d'atteindre ses 4800 cette nette 6 h un
jeune soldat d'années de cela c'est à
ses pieds qu'il a planté sa tente
l'année dernière ils étaient déjà là un
été dramatique son meilleur ami est mort
à ses côtés mais il n'empêche la passion
est trop forte et ihe recommence de
convenance
c'est l'appel de la montagne c'est la
passion fort que l'an dernier mon ami
avait fait une faute
j'ai beaucoup appris après ce drame je
ne recommencerai pas cette faute
je ne répéterai pas une erreur par et
répété et c'est ainsi que par passion
par curiosité chaque matin
professionnelle ou débutants se lance à
l'assaut des sommets
mais la montagne n'est pas un terrain de
jeu inoffensif des pièges sont à éviter
beaucoup d'alpinistes l'oubli certains
ont payé de leur vie
moi ce qui m'attriste c'est de voir des
gens des gens qui souffrent dans cette
montagne
dans un univers aussi beau c'est un peu
dommage et des fois c'est un peu dommage
simple bêtise ça se termine en drame
marché en haute altitude évoluer sur
glacier c'est avant tout avoir du
matériel adapté trop d'accidents
surviennent par manque d'équipement une
corde et n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
ils étaient équipés de baudriers de
cordes des crampons de piolets et
crampons puisque la neige est un peu
moins cette équipe et d'anti bottes pour
lever le pied on pense que c'est des
antipodes c'est cette partie ici en
caoutchouc qui évite que la neige
colsoul crampons voilà on a une sécurité
optimale pour faire cette course qu'on
se déplacer sur ce terrain des vêtements
déchirés des ecchymoses martin souris
mais elle revient de loin
une chute de plusieurs dizaines de
mètres j'aime partir première sur le
rocher après sept journées six plus tard
on n'est pas dans le bon sens si tu
penses que le piolet hyperbole donc ça
va mieux
tu fais ça sur un mur de 200 mètres de
glace je sais pas la rue des commandes
t1 comme martin beaucoup n'ont pas vu
venir la fatigue la faute d'inattention
et en quelques secondes le pire peut
survenir
et puis il ya cette mystérieuse ivresse
des montagnes qui fait que parfois on va
au delà de ses limites juste pour le
plaisir
il ya des risques maintenant au fait
qu'un champion on se dit que ça sera pas
mouiller 2 1
on fait très attention et de deux si on
le termine et vieux c'est vrai que quand
on donne souvent mal au début on lance
un petit peu un petit peu plus de
risques mais ça se calme 15,4 en otage
plus de cinq mille personnes par jour
sillonnent ses sommets la plupart le
font avec prudence car comment ne pas
s'émerveiller face à tant de beauté face
à ce moulin qui vous offrent
l'hospitalité beau ce matin j'ai envie
de pleurer parce que c'était vachement
beau c'était formidable
on est arrivé là où c'était magnifique
c'était et bon d'autant plus que pour
moi c'était quelque chose particulier
puisque c'est pour l'anniversaire de mes
50 ans les copains ils m'ont offert ça
alors je trouve que c'est fabuleux j'ai
envie de pleurer
c'est fort bien
les obsèques de jeanne calment auront
lieu demain après midi dans la plus
stricte intimité un hommage plus
solennelle sera rendu jeudi à la plus
célèbre des arlésiennes à l'occasion
d'une messe à la cathédrale de la ville
a roulé après la disparition de jeanne
calment le doyen de l'humanité est sans
doute désormais un américain d'origine
danoise christian mortensen qui fêtera
ses 115 ans le 16 août prochain dans la
maison de retraite où il vit en
californie voilier s'ils n'empêchent pas
de fuites d'eau commentant un petit
cigare pour la forme on ne sait pas
encore précisément qui a désormais
l'honneur d'être le doyen ou la doyenne
des français des françaises christophe
la rocca et olivier combe nous
rencontrer l'une des candidates aux
tripes
elle s'appelle maria elle habite dans le
lot et elle a soufflé ses 110 bougies de
26 heures ville de marjah laborie c'est
elle mais elle n'est à ce jour qu'une
des candidates à la succession de jeanne
calment en france aucun organisme tient
à jour un recensement des personnes très
âgées alors un peu partout dans
l'hexagone
on a sorti les livrets de famille comme
ici à saint siège dans le lot où l'on
estime qu'à 110 ans maria mérite bien le
titre de doyenne des français même si la
principale intéressée elle n'a pas cette
ambition
maria est née le 26 avril 1896 elle a
toujours vécu dans le même village
outre sa fille qui vit près d'elle elle
a deux petits enfants trois arrière
petits enfants
et depuis cinq jours un arrière-arrière
petit-fils mais personne n'a su lui
arrachait le secret le salon est ce
qu'elle a un secret votre mère pour
vivre aussi vieux je ne sais pas qui
nous l'a jamais confiante au lit et je
crois qu'elle aime beaucoup les
sucreries c'est vrai oui du riz du sucre
et des pleins les bains elle se surpasse
maria devra encore attendre quelques
jours pour ça
car si sa gourmandise lui a permis
d'atteindre le rang du doyenne des
français car d'ores et déjà plusieurs
autres anciens lui conteste ce titre la
cour d'appel de bordeaux annoncera après
demain jeudi si maurice papon y placer
ou non sous contrôle judiciaire avant
son procès pour crimes contre l'humanité
un procès qui s'ouvrira le 8 octobre à
bordeaux le procureur général estime je
cite que tout risque de soustraction de
l'accusé à l'action de la justice n'est
pas à exclure sur place françois privat
fabien cordier dans 48 heures les
magistrats de la chambre d'accusation de
la cour d'appel de bordeaux se
prononceront sur la mise sous contrôle
judiciaire de maurice papon
concrètement l'ancien secrétaire général
de la préfecture de gironde sous le
régime de vichy ne pourrez plus quitter
le territoire français avant l'ouverture
de son procès le 8 octobre prochain
l'exemple de paul touvier entrée libre à
la cour d'assises de versailles et qui
en est ressorti avec une peine de prison
à perpétuité peut l'inciter à vouloir
prendre la fuite hors du territoire
français
et c'est pour ça que nous avons demandé
que lui soit appliqué à une messe des
mesures de contrôle judiciaire ce qui
est le minimum puisque ça n'empêche pas
de fuir clandestinement mais maintenant
il ne pourra pas fuir en tous les cas
légalement pendant un peu moins de deux
heures à huis clos
les magistrats ont entendu le procureur
général qui pour le parquet de bordeaux
a réclamé que l'ancien ministre de
valéry giscard d'estaing remette ses
papiers d'identité et son passeport à la
justice
mais pour son avocat jean-marc varaut
maurice papon ne cherchera en aucun cas
à fuir son procès je sais qu'on veulent
provoquer à s'en aller par des mesures
de cette sorte
mais il a toujours demandé à être jugé
et il ne s'est jamais dérobé à sa parole
vivant il sera devant la cour
quelques représentants des parties
civiles étaient présents à la fin de
l'audience
selon leur porte parole michel slitinsky
aps le placement sous contrôle
judiciaire de maurice papon serait une
mesure légitime dans l'intérêt de la
vérité c'est une bien ténébreuse affaire
qui agite auxerre et sa région il y a
une vingtaine d'années cette jeune fille
handicapée mentale légère et sous
tutelle de la das ont disparu sans
laisser de traces
après bien des péripéties la cour
d'appel de paris avait ordonné en mai
dernier l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire
or l'homme qui connaissaient le mieux le
dossier un gendarme vient de mourir dans
des conditions encore mal éclaircies
enquête verifone you feel turbo entre
1977 et 79,8 jeunes filles ont disparu
dans la région d'auxerre 8 handicapée
mentale légère toutes issues de la dass
seule une d'entre elles a été retrouvée
morte
officiellement un meurtre et cette fugue
ma soeur n'aurait jamais fugué
c'est c'est en prenant le cas cette
parole avec 13 hôtels a bien été vu au
quart longtemps dans le cas sa soeur
madeleine de justes a disparu de la gare
routière d'auxerre en 77 20 ans ont
passé
le foyer de la dass où elle a grandi est
aujourd'hui fermé mais sa soeur se
souvient bien des événements qui ont
suivi sa disparition elle qui a tenté de
la retrouver l amisom on avait des coups
de téléphone anonymes la nuit tout ça et
il y en avait à une femme pouvait
arriver sarine syndicats fallait soigner
un peu de ça râle et là j'ai une voiture
la course et mon mari et mon frère les
soigner jusqu'à michel lis encore pu
voir qui c'était vous avez été menacée
oui elle cessera aussitôt de rechercher
la vérité
à l'époque à auxerre on ne parle pas
encore de disparition en série le hasard
va pousser deux hommes a mené une
véritable enquête
un gendarme christian jambert cherche à
élucider un meurtre et jacques moreau ce
commerçant qui assistait à l'époque le
juge pour enfants en quête lui sur une
disparition
ils établiront qu'il s'agit en fait de
la même personne intrigué il rouvre tous
les dossiers de disparitions
inexpliquées premier suspect un
chauffeur de car le chauffeur de car à
l'époque était la dernière personne vu
en compagnie des disparus juste avant
leur disparition
et pourquoi il n'a jamais été inquiété
sur le dossier classé par le juge
d'instruction sans suite
l'homme connaît pourtant très bien
certains disparus lui qui les transporte
tous les jours il est même l'amant de
l'une d'elle françoise lemoine qu'il
installe avec sa soeur bernadette dans
un hôtel de sers douanes disparaîtront
quinze jours après leur arrivée
jacqueline vice elle dit déplacés par la
date chez la concubine du chauffeur de
car un jour il prétendu avoir trouvé un
emploi à avallon l'emmène à la gare elle
n'arrivera jamais à destination
deux ans plus tard ce même chauffeur lit
avec une autre femme qui élève elle
aussi des enfants de la dass et là aussi
une jeune fille disparaît elle était
donc élevée chez lui chez lui et cette
jeune fille a été retrouvé à quelques
centaines de mètres de son domicile
on va après où le corps avait été très
rapidement détérioré ne restait plus que
des os c'est peut-être du trou à nouveau
possible des protections
autre fait troublant toutes les jeunes
filles disparues en véhicule à un moment
donné ici dans cet institut dont le
directeur a été condamné pour
attouchements sur une mineure de
l'établissement un homme qui est
d'ailleurs l'ami du chauffeur de car et
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là ce fameux
chauffeur a été condamné deux fois pour
attouchements sur mineurs en 80 et 89
tout ça ce sont des pistes absolument
extraordinaire mais que l'homme n'a
jamais expliqué que l'on n'a pas voulu
exploiter
je dis que c'est un réflexe de répulsion
à l'encontre d'une enquête qui peut
déboucher sur la découverte de vis
particulièrement aux grands à auxerre ou
dans la région de serre les familles et
l'association des disparues de l'yonne
ont obtenu il ya trois mois
la réouverture du dossier il avait porté
plainte pour refus d'informer de la part
du nouveau juge d'instruction
on peut fabuler on peut dire des choses
près ce procès il ya des entraîneurs qui
sont désignés
et nous verrons bien pour par la suite
vous faites allusion aux rumeurs à tout
ce qui peut être dit dans dans serre sur
une volonté farouche que d'étouffer la
faire la rumeur ça a toujours existé
il est impossible d'imaginer ce à
l'instant que justin souciant peu
protégé s'il y en a un ou plusieurs des
criminels
le dossier actuel est bien mince il ne
comporte aucune des investigations
menées à l'époque par le gendarme
jambert un gendarme qui devait être
entendue par le juge
hasard ou pas il est mort hier c'était
un témoin essentiel pour élucider le
dossier des disparus d'auxerre
l'association française des usagers des
banques vient de révéler un nouveau type
de fraude à la carte bancaire qui sévit
en france depuis la mi mai reportage
frédéric rault tanisha giannoulas tous
et piles si l'iran kenya il ya un
inconnu vous offre non pas des fleurs
mais son aide devant un guichet
automatique lieu d'un romantisme rares
méfiant depuis quelques mois des
fraudeurs ont trouvé une nouvelle
arnaque
dans un premier temps il neutralise le
système de lecture de cartes en insérant
un petit bout de carton qui va arriver à
se retrouver devant un distributeur qui
ne fonctionne pas le fraudeur la plupart
du temps de lui conseiller de composer
son code confidentiel
ainsi va pouvoir le bim
visualisez le produire s'éloigne alors
laissant sa victime persuadé que la
carte est certes un valet mais en
sécurité erreur en forçant l'appareil à
l'aide d'un tournevis
le fraudeur qui a déjà le code récupère
la carte
heureusement seulement quelques
appareils du crédit lyonnais du cic en
région parisienne peuvent être piratés
de la sorte au crédit lyonnais
on essaie de minimiser la faire il n'y a
pas de problème particulier
il ya des machines distributeur de
billets quand étaient détruites ou
détériorés abîmés par des gens et le
tournevis et c'est donc vous contestez
qu'il y ait par jour une quinzaine de
personnes qu'ils soient victimes de
fraudeurs et pourtant dans une note
adressée à ses adhérents l'association
française des banques reconnaît
l'importance de cette escroquerie
l'association des usagers des banques
elle recommande une extrême vigilance
mis en service aujourd'hui d'une partie
du nouveau périphérique de lyon dit et e
outrance est ouest inauguration sans
inauguration en catimini sans tambour ni
trompette car semi autoroute à péage 16
francs pour 10 km suscite localement de
nombreuses polémiques notamment sur le
contrat de concession
reportage benoît gallerey olivier jacque
là
s'il vous plaît c'est un comité
d'accueil un peu spécial que les
automobilistes ont découvert aujourd'hui
en empruntant pour la première fois le
périphérique nord des usagers en colère
invitant les automobilistes à signer une
pétition pétition contre les tarifs de
cette nouvelle voie rapide jusqu'à 16
francs pour 10 km entre l'est et l'ouest
de l'agglomération lyonnaise et d'une
certaine façon le périphérique coûte
encore plus à ceux qui ne l'empruntent
pas bouchons en perspective pour les
récalcitrants car plusieurs voix proche
celle qui constitue un itinéraire de
rechange ont été rétrécies
histoire d'inciter les automobilistes à
rouler sur le nouveau périphérique dans
le contrat du concessionnaire il est
écrit noir sur blanc que la puissance
publique doit rétrécir les voies qui
revêt avant de périphériques
donc on a mis en place un système qui
fait que les lyonnais sont obligés de
payer une taxe
un consortium bouygues dumestre le
contrat de concession a été signé pour
35 ans avec le consortium bouygues dumez
à l'époque michel noir présidait la
communauté urbaine de lyon
il a été examiné il a été approuvé par
le conseil d'état à l'époque
je sache personne ne trouvait trop à
redire à ce contrat à part quelques
composants classiques donc ce contrat
existe s'il doit être modifié il peut
toujours l'être en reprenant par l'impôt
une partie des péages c'est pas
personnellement ce que ce soit j'ai pas
le sentiment que ce soit super chouette
la gérant général les lyonnais les
opposants ont déposé un recours auprès
du tribunal administratif
le concessionnaire lui tente de calmer
les esprits jusqu'au 10 août
le périphérique est gratuit nouveau
problème à bord de la station mir juste
avant l'arrivée des dépanneurs de
l'espace deux générateurs d'oxygène ont
rendu l'âme si je puis dire en revanche
décollage sans problème pour la fusée
soyouz qui a mis sur orbite la capsule
spatiale en menant les deux cosmonautes
russes chargés de réparer les dégâts
patrice pollet 17h36 heure de paris
la fusée soyouz s'arrache du pas de tir
de baïkonour à gauche
anatoly solo veuve le commandant de bord
le plus expérimenté des cosmonautes
russes à droite
pavel vinogradov ingénieur de bord une
grosse tête en informatique
c'est sur les épaules de ces deux hommes
que repose depuis cet après midi
l'écrasante responsabilité de sauver la
station oui
une station qui se portent de plus en
plus mal juste avant que l'équipage
l'embarquent on apprenait qu'un nouvel
incident affectait de nouveau la
plateforme spatiale deux générateurs
d'oxygène rendu l'âme il y à quelques
jours du travail supplémentaire leur a
annoncé le ministre de la défense russe
nous ferons le maximum ont répondu les
deux heures
c'est vrai que le travail ne va pas
manquer avec comme premier objectif la
poursuite de la station mir qui tourne à
28 milles kilomètres heure
arrivé sur place il faudra sarine et en
douceur
ensuite commencera la répétition de la
réparation et c'est des combinaisons et
de l'entrée dans le module spectre il
était pressurisée l'oxygène s'échappe
par un trou de 3 cm à l'intérieur du
module il re brancheront les tables des
panneaux solaires pour récupérer un peu
d'énergie électrique
l'opération se déroulera dans quinze
jours les deux hommes devront faire
preuve d'une grande habileté la plus
petite déchirure dans une combinaison
leur laisserait peu de chances de
survivre nouvelle escalade dans
l'horreur en algérie ou au moins 75
civils ont été massacrés dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi certains journaux
algériens font même état d'un bilan
total 210 morts depuis les législatives
début juin au moins 700 civils ont été
tués pour ne pas dire massacrés alors
que dimanche le président zeroual appelé
ses concitoyens à une vigilance accrues
face aux attentats les incidents ont
éclaté la nuit dernière à cayenne en
guyane après l'annnonce du maintien en
détention préventive d'un militant
indépendantiste mise en examen pour
avoir frappé un policier les forces de
l'ordre ont chargé pour faire dégager
quelques 200 manifestants rassemblés
devant l'hôtel de police de cayenne
manifestants qui ont péri j'ai des
barrages improvisés dans plusieurs rues
du centre ville
cinq personnes ont été interpellées aux
comores le gouvernement a placé ses
troupes en état d' alerte après la clope
proclamation de l'indépendance par les
séparatiste de l'île d'anjouan
séparatistes qui demande à être à
nouveau à nice très par la france et
séparatistes certains les appellent
rattachistes ont élu un président et ils
ont promis un référendum avant la fin de
la
précision jean bernard schmidt cet homme
abdallah ibrahim a été élu aujourd'hui
président de l'état dans jouant à 71 ans
ce professeur d'école coranique et le
chef des séparatistes de l'île
comorienne qui ont proclamé
l'indépendance dimanche
à peine nommé abdallah ibrahim a
constitué un gouvernement provisoire et
annoncé la tenue d'élections avant la
fin de l'année il entend ainsi obtenir
le soutien officiel du peuple l'avenir
les habitants dans jouant le verrait
bien aux couleurs de la france à
laquelle ils demandent à être rattachés
l'armée comorienne a été placées en état
d' alerte et s'il est difficile de
mesurer la part exacte de la population
qui suivait séparatistes e s'affirme
prêt à résister
l'armée aura des problèmes pour faire
face la population s'engagera par le
combat militaire et la violent cette
tentative de sécession de l'île
d'anjouan est un nouvel épisode de
l'histoire mouvementée des comores en 75
trois des quatre îles qui composent cet
archipel des sites par référendum de
leur indépendance
seul mayotte a choisi de rester
française depuis leur accession à la
souveraineté
les comores ont été secouées par 17
coups d'état dont plusieurs organisé par
le mercenaire français bob denard une
instabilité permanente qui inspire la
plus grande prudence à la france paris
qui est dans le passé déjà intervenues
pour rétablir l'ordre
aux comores estime ce soir qu'il s'agit
là d'une affaire intérieure nouvelles
découvertes encourageante dans le
traitement de la maladie de parkinson
une équipe française annonce en effet
avoir établi chez le rat la possibilité
d'un traitement préventif génétique de
cette maladie un travail qui ouvre la
voie à une expérimentation sur l'homme
reportage de gilles marine et jean-marc
source à des amis avaient remarqué que
quand je marchais que j'avais
bras pour sept ans que je n'avais plus
le ballon du bras et c'est à partir de
là que il a fallu selon contracture
admettent qu'ils avaient quelque chose
qui n'était pas normal j'ai construit un
parking
c'était il ya vingt ans depuis on est
militant a perdu en grande partie la
maîtrise de ses membres les médicaments
existent mais ils ne peuvent que
ralentir la progression du mal c'est à
dire la dégénérescence des neurones qui
contrôle la motricité au microscope on
constate que ceux-ci les taches noires
disparaissent peu à peu
le véritable traitement consisterait
donc à bloquer l'évolution de la maladie
les scientifiques du cnrs penses tu y
parvenir nous travaux suggèrent qu'il
est tout à fait envisageable
d'intervenir en nommant précoce pour
prévenir ou freiner la dégénérescence
des neurones impliqués dans la motricité
c'est ce que l'on peut espérer sur la
base des résultats que l'on obtient chez
le rend l'expérience a consisté à
introduire dans le cerveau de rats
encore sein des jeunes protecteur puis à
déclencher la maladie
on s'est alors aperçu que les jeunes
avaient bien rempli leur mission
l'introduit donc ce gène qui permet de
synthétiser une protéine qui va protéger
les neurones les empêcher donc de
dégénérer de mourir la maladie est
stoppé par cette substance et cela dès
les débuts cette thérapie génique est
elle transposable à l'homme il faudra
encore cinq à dix ans l'expérimentation
avant de connaître la réponse
alors que la polémique se poursuit sur
l'origine et surtout sur la mauvaise
organisation de la lutte contre l'
incendie de forêt qui a menacé récemment
la banlieue de marseille
les spécialistes de la protection civile
rappelle qu'en france l'homme est
responsable 9 fois sur 10 des incendies
forêts que ce soit la simple imprudence
ou la volonté criminelle
en corse on vit actuellement les
journées les plus risqués d'où une
vigilance tout à fait exceptionnelle
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
jacques cardoze pour nos libertés
une chaleur étouffante un soleil brûlant
ces militaires restent postés des
journées entières sur cette crête pour
dissuader seulement dissuader cela fait
partie du dispositif de surveillance
car en matière de lutte contre les
incendies la corse a ses spécificités
maquis pinette forêt de pins fond du
massif montagneux un secteur
particulièrement accidenté et difficile
d'accès mais il n'ya pas que cela au
codis de bastia cela fait déjà plusieurs
années qu'une carte des zones à risques
circule une carte des pyromanes à
l'origine de 20% des départs de feu je
pense qu'on arrive maintenant à de bons
résultats et je crois aussi
il me semble sentir du moins un
changement de comportement donc on a
tendance à se rapprocher
je dirais de ce qui se passe dans la
salle les départements du sud de la
france les résultats s'améliorent parce
que la vigilance s'accroît en balagne
chaque secteur a son lot des équipes de
surveillance terrestre des équipes
adapté à cette fameuse carte de pyromane
exemple c'est forestiers-sapeurs protège
d'une forêt de pins
si elle brûle en étaient les mots ripoux
seront plus vite en automne
leur présence a suffi à faire reculer
les petits malins candidats à une
cueillette lucratif des champignons et
puis à chute c'est un travail à l'année
on travaille même principe dans le
maquis où les éleveurs brûlent leurs
parcelles de terre conséquence au
printemps suivant l'herbe pousse
abondamment
le travail de la sécurité civile ne
s'arrête donc pas à cela la seule
maîtrise du feu en corse depuis cinq ans
la quantité d'hectares brûlés a diminué
de moitié mais à quel prix ce jour-là
canadair et tracker ont pu maîtriser
rapidement les trois petits hectares qui
surplombe la maison de ce particulier
lui n'avait aucun intérêt à voir ces
terres brûlées
ce n'est pas le cas de tous l'année
passée en balagne 122 mise à feu ont été
concentrées dans un secteur de 150
hectares après la pointe du raz et les
rochers de ploumanac'h un autre site
breton très appréciée des touristes va
se refaire très prochainement une petite
santé le cap fréhel dont la végétation a
été en quelque sorte victime de son
succès
reportage jacques debout ni chalifert le
cap fréhel est un des joyaux de la
bretagne nord des falaises de grès rose
repère des oiseaux de mina maire de 80
mètres de haut un site grandiose mais le
cap fréhel c'est aussi cela une centaine
d'hectares ravagés par le piétinement
des visites les promeneurs élargissent
des chemins qui atteignent parfois
quatre mètres de véritables route au
plus près de la mer le cap n'est plus
qu'une terrasse rocheuses où l'herbe a
disparu ici ça va dans tous les sens
donc on arrive à la pointe les gens vont
d'un bout de la pointe à l'autre dans
tous les sens et on se retrouve avec
toute l'habitation piétiner donc en
faisant un cheminement dans l'arc dans
le sur le tour en bord de falaise
on va pouvoir préserver le centre que
les amateurs de sensations fortes se
rassurent l'accès à la falaise ne sera
pas interdite mais en proposant des
cheminements l'érosion sera limité la
réalisation s'inspirera de ce qui a été
fait à quelques kilomètres de là au cap
d'erquy un simple fil tendu le long des
chemins a permis à la langue de
reconquérir le terrain ici on voit très
très bien donc à cet emplacement
quelle tête quel est l état en fait du
site avant restauration
à côté on a donc une illustration de ce
que pourrait être finalement cet espace
après une simple mise en défens c'est à
dire l'installation d'une petite clôture
monofil à ma cm du sol qui suggère
simplement
un circuit sans obliger qui que ce soit
finalement à le respecter et bien la
nature très facilement fait le reste
on tente de recoloniser l'ensemble de de
l'espace mais cela ne s'est pas fait en
un jour
cinq années ont été nécessaires et la
reprise de la lande est encore fragile
or au cap fréhel
la tâche est bien plus conséquente les
travaux doivent démarrer cet hiver mais
aucun calendrier n'est encore établi
tout à l'heure à vous l'avez vu
peut-être en direct sur france 3 aux
championnats du monde d'athlétisme
d'athènes
michael jackson a conservé son titre
mondial sur 400 m en ce moment un temps
de 44 secondes 12 centièmes devant le
camp d'aida l'izk à moga médaille
d'argent et un autre américain tyree
washington
le champion olympique du 200 et 400 m a
book le rassurer ses amis rappeurs il
avait à peine fini seulement à la
quatrième place lors des quarts de
finale hier soir dans l'épreuve du 400 m
haies stéphane diagana est devenu le
premier français champion du monde
d'athlétisme
jacques chirac lui a adressé ses plus
chaleureuses félicitations au terme d'un
tour de piste qui restera dans les
annales de l'athlétisme
le chef de l'état salue d'autre part une
victoire qui vient après des plusieurs
mois de doute et de souffrance il est
vrai que stéphane diagana avait connu
plutôt la galère ces derniers temps
c'est donc une formidable consécration
pour cet athlète exemplaire reportage de
notre envoyé spécial à athènes laurent
frédéric bollée
stéphane diagana ou la victoire de la
simplicité et de la gentillesse
voici un athlète que tout le monde aime
bien et la ferveur des embrassades après
son triomphe est là pour le prouver
stéphane diagana ou l'ami fidèle à la
recherche d'une consécration qu'enfin
ils arrachent
stéphane diagana où l'homme pudique pour
qui faire un tour d'honneur représente
presque une audace stéphane diagana où
l'athlète réservé et secret stéphane
diagana
ce sont ses amis qui en parlent le mieux
on a une passion commune c'est
c'est la vie la liberté le bonheur et on
arrive à le transmettre dans l'entente
travers de la musique d'une part mais
surtout au travers de grands événements
comme celui ci aujourd'hui
stéphane diagana où le fils modèle là
ses parents l'ont toujours soutenu son
entraîneur l'a toujours défendu
wesley sneijd'or moi je suis pas son
père son père je suis pas son nom plus
je suis quelqu'un qui est auprès de lui
qui le conseillent au moment qu'il
convient mais c'est son papa et sa maman
qui ont fait son éducation et lé
remarque stéphane diagana où l'esprit
libre sportif et intellectuels féru de
mathématiques et de biologie champion du
monde et président du groupement des
athlètes français volonté de s'investir
fierté de représenter l'équipe de france
est en train de prouver que c'est
vraiment un grand leader est derrière
nous maintenant je vais lui demander
maintenant d'être le vrai capital
puisqu'il a fini par y aura le 4.4
encore qui peut encore mieux faire de
belles surprises
tu est demandé maintenant de pousser un
petit peu tout le monde stéphane diagana
où la vertu récompensés on ne lui
connaît que des amis cet athlète est
donc aussi à sa façon un esthète accorde
dans le tarn le festival la mémoire des
pierres porte bien son nom c'est tôt
cité médiévale a créé ce besoin de
rappeler en 1912 122 par le comte de
toulouse reconstitue son histoire avec
ses habitants pour figurants et ses
bastides pour décor reportage bruno
albin marc trichard mon maître est une
masse de plomb mais il n'a pas y est
d'or et prix c'est l'histoire d'un
alchimiste
mais la vraie vedette de la mémoire des
pierres est une cité médiévale aux
confins du pays cathare cordes-sur-ciel
l'un des plus beaux villages de france
pour guider le spectateur à travers
l'histoire de ses habitants on a marié
le cinéma et la scène pour dire
laventure d'un alchimiste xviiie siècle
à la recherche de son passé
claude rich se mêlent chaque soir aux
habitants de cordes fier de faire
revivre leur histoire
si notre occitanie est une terre
d'accueil c'est parce que d'abord ça a
été avant de tout depuis des siècles une
terre d'intégration
c'est à dire que les événements
tragiques qui l'ont secoué
on développe et beaucoup de tolérance de
générosité je voudrais que ça continue
c'est un message qui doit passer on
notera remettre à tous ceux qui viennent
qu'il amène ailleurs avec l'alternance
de la mise en scène en plein air et des
séquences filmées les siècles se
télescopent les grandes peurs du
moyen-âge l'inquisition les templiers
tous les grands thèmes de l'histoire
occitane se succèdent le décor les
maisons de cordes et les sculptures
qatar accrochés à leurs façades
authentique et mystérieuse ce sont elles
qui ont inspiré le récit de la mémoire
des pierres
nous somme n'est pas cool pop ne sait
pas lire les sculptures de cette époque
sont symboliques et exprime une pensée
il suffit de retrouver l'état de pensée
de l'époque pour essayer de déchiffrer
la mémoire des pierres ne prétend pas
expliquer ni l'histoire cathare ni la
quête des alchimistes
mais le spectacle est une invitation à
mieux regarder la ville qui l'a inspiré
et à se laisser entraîner les vieilles
murailles ont ceci en commun avec les
alchimistes qui rêvait de transmuter le
plomb en or leur pierre transforme le
vin mystère en scène curiosité deux
hommes en noir viennent de faire main
basse sur le box office américain comme
on dit le film men in black vienne n'en
vient en effet de rafler plus d'un
milliard de francs de recettes en quatre
semaines aux états unis cette comédie
décalée et sur fond de science fiction
débarque demain sur 400 écrans français
y colle comme il en fait non je ne veux
rien merci madame
que ces agents très spéciaux les
envahisseurs extraterrestres font partie
du quotidien pour nous protéger à notre
insu ils doivent contrôler tous ceux qui
viennent d'ailleurs et ce n'est pas de
tout repos car aucun et ce qui semble
être
je ne fais plus partie du système
vous êtes au dessus du système au sommet
au delà nous sommes e somme il nous
sommes les mannequins double a et ce
n'est pas un hasard si will smith a
choisi la tour eiffel pour nous parler
de ses activités intergalactique vous
que la tour eiffel et le centre vous
rappellerai ce que sur les terres la
tour eiffel est une antenne que les
extraterrestres utilisent pour
transmettre des informations
en fin d'après midi
atterrissage non autorisée quelque part
au nord de new york
je suis de new york l extraterrestre
répandent des traces ferté à tort
laussucq là ils ont dit à questions pour
un champion yafran en si de bach à part
le comique n'est de l'affrontement entre
la placidité de l'aîné et l'excitation
de la nouvelle recrue mais l'enjeu est
énorme déjouer les complots pour sauver
encore une fois notre bonne vieille
terre
ok j'ai sauvé la planète dans une
dépanneuse des jeux les sauver dans la
lah maintenant je pense que je vais me
reposer un peu hein et puis pour l'an
prochain on laissera tom cruise et
arnold schwarzenneger sont occupés
le petit bouton vrais appuis sur le
petit bouton rouge
ces hommes en noir s'adapte aux
situations les plus extraordinaires ou
plutôt extra planétaire et rien ne les
étonne ni de faire la couverture de
magazine américain ni de battre tous les
records d'entrées encore moins de
tutoyer des créatures surnaturelles deux
films au programme ce soir sur france 2
plus beau que moi tu meurs et tais toi
quand tu parles je vais m'en passer
d'obtempérer
non sans vous avoir rappelé votre
rendez-vous et que laurence ostolaza
pour le tout dernier journal vers 00h20
demain dans les 4 vérités à 16h50
rémy roche recevra le président du
secours populaire bon anniversaire à
raquel welch et à l'abbé pierre 85 ans
aujourd'hui la météo dans un instant
nathalie rihouet toujours oh rage ô
désespoir très très bonne soirée merci
coming next harbour
bah quoi